bonjour à toutes et à tous
est-ce que vous appuyez sur le bouton de
fermeture des portes de l'ascenseur
est-ce que ça vous est né d'arriver 5
heures en avance à l'aéroport pour
attendre votre avion pendant 4 heures 30
moi ça m'emmerde
d'ailleurs la dernière fois que j'ai
pris l'avion
c'était pour aller à Séoul en Corée du
Sud
je ne connaissais absolument rien à ce
pays j'y allais dans l'optique d'étudier
mais aussi de découvrir de nouvelles
cultures de sortir de mon cadre de
référence et de vivre cette nouvelle
culture
ça tombe bien j'ai réussi
en Corée j'ai été invité à un mariage
mais en plus d'être invité à ce mariage
on m'a demandé de chanter et danser
devant tout le monde
j'ai bien sûr du apprendre à répéter ce
champ est cette danse
il ne me demandez pas de le faire
en Corée je suis allé dans une agence
signée pour un nouveau logement je suis
allé au commissariat pour porter plainte
pour un vol de téléphone
je suis allé deux fois au bar de faux au
restaurant de fois en boîte de nuit
[Musique]
j'ai pris trois fois le Taxi 2 fois le
bus et deux fois le métro
enfin je suis allé sur les bords de la
halle River le fleuve qui traverse Séoul
en une journée
car oui encore il est tout va très vite
on utilise souvent l'expression palipali
qui signifie vite vite en coréen pour
décrire la société coréenne
on connaît on est servi en 5 minutes au
restaurant
un magasin de chaussures peut devenir un
bar en angle
on se met en couple après s'être
rencontré pour la deuxième fois
un mariage dure une heure
et je ne vous parle pas de la rapidité
de la connexion internet ni des
transports
[Musique]
dans ce pays et qui voulait absolument
tout faire tout vivre tout voir
j'avais trouvé le pays parfait pour moi
le pays où je pouvais me doucher me
brosser les dents et faire pipi en même
temps
un sentiment de frustration ma vitesse
j'avais toujours l'impression de ne pas
avoir le temps de faire tout ce que je
voulais
et plus ce voyage avancé moins il me
restait de temps pour profiter et plus
je me demandais si j'avais déjà
réellement profité
à la fin de cette journée dont je vous
ai parlé
je suis passé par un
sur ce configurer différentes phrases en
Corée
on pouvait lire
vous en avez marre d'être seul
essaye encore un peu
le meilleur est à venir
ces messages sont destinés à dissuader
les gens de se suicider en sautant de ce
coup
c'est à ce moment là que j'ai commencé à
me questionner
sur cette culture du palipali cette
culture tout va très vite et ses
conséquences
à force
d'interroger mes amis et de me
documenter
j'ai appris que les Coréens subissent
aussi cette culture et ce rythme de vie
effréné
la Corée est un des pays où l'on dormait
moins et où l'on travaille le plus
on dort en moyenne 7 heures 41 par nuit
c'est une heure de moins qu'en France
et le temps de travail légal maximal et
de 52 heures par semaine
on est loin des 35 heures
les Coréens subissent aussi une pression
constante tant dans leur vie personnelle
que professionnelle
il en résulte d'un taux de suicide très
élevé près de 25 personnes sur 100 000
c'est le plus haut taux de suicides
parmi les pays membres de l'OCDE
j'ai aussi repensé à différents
événements comme l'effondrement d'un
immeuble suite à des défauts de
construction en 1995
ou le naufrage d'un ferry suite à des
négligences humaine en 2014
ou encore la bousculade d'Halloween en
[Musique]
ils sont tous en partie le résultat de
cette culture ou tout va très vite cette
culture où tout va trop vite
j'ai donc remarqué que ce rythme de vie
peut avoir un aspect néfaste de manière
individuelle mais aussi collectif
à l'image de la Corée
l'hyperactivité règne sur le monde
le monde entier cherche toujours plus de
rapidité
tant dans la vie personnelle que en
entreprise ou en politique
je ne pense pas que nous puissions
changer ça
l'homme cherche naturellement à
progresser
je me suis donc demandé
comment gérer mon temps et comment
aborder le futur dans un monde où tout
va toujours plus vite
pour répondre à cette question
j'ai cherché les différences entre ma
vie en France et ma vie en Corée
la différence majeure et que en France
je ne suis beaucoup moins au milieu des
parents
en France j'ai des moments de calme de
repos
des moments où je m'ennuie ou je n'ai
rien à faire je n'ai rien de prévu
[Musique]
en France parfois je dois attendre au
restaurant je dois attendre pour faire
ce truc je dois attendre à l'arrêt de
bus
je n'avais plus du tout ces moments en
Corée
et au lieu de chérir le temps que
j'avais j'ai cherché à tout optimiser à
la minute près
au point même de ne plus me souvenir de
ce que j'avais fait la veille j'étais
toujours le premier à dire palipali
et à subir ce stress de ne pas avoir le
temps de faire tout ce que je voulais
un jour
peut-être en France à l'image de la
Corée je n'aurai plus tous ces moments
d'ennuis d'inactivité
peut-être que vous déjà vous cherchez
ces moments entre métro boulot dodo
le ménage le chien les enfants
sur tous les enfants
[Musique]
il nous faut donc développer une
nouvelle manière de vivre
une vie qui s'articulerait sur
l'équilibre entre les moments
d'agitation et les moments de calme
d'inactivité une vie à deux vitesses
avec un rythme pour le repos et un
rythme pour le travail
une vie où l'on ne chercherait non pas
tout en la vitesse mais parfois la
lenteur
une vie où l'on arriverait à s'imposer
des moments calmes déconnectés au rythme
de la nature
certaines sociétés comme Air France ou
SNCF ont d'ailleurs déjà très bien
compris
dans la publicité elle est ne promène
pas un trajet rapide mais une parenthèse
de lenteur
ou un moment donné de tranquillité
qui a écrit ce texte
c'est pour ça que peut chercher les mots
des sociétés comme Air France ou SNCF
nous promettent donc un moment de paix
de tranquillité
on connaît d'ailleurs déjà très bien les
bénéfices liés au fait de prendre le
temps
lié au fait de prendre des temps de
pause
d'un point de vue professionnel par
exemple
une étude menée à Harvard Business
School au sein du Boston Consulting
Group
a montré que les employés qui se rendent
inaccessibles un jour par semaine à
partir de 18h
était plus satisfait de leur équilibre
entre vie professionnelle et vie
personnelle que leurs collègues
ils sont aussi plus satisfaits de leur
travail et ils ont été plus nombreux à
émettre le souhait de rester dans
l'entreprise
d'un point de vue personnel aussi car
cette frénésie de la vitesse
nous donne le sentiment de ne jamais
avoir le temps
et de ne plus réussir à suivre on va
jusqu'à perturber nos rythmes
biologiques
entraînant du stress de la fatigue et
différentes maladies
une autre étude menée à
a montré que prendre le temps et avoir
un cerveau reposer permettre une
réflexion plus profonde plus intense et
plus mesurée
et améliorent ainsi le bonheur et la
qualité de vie
c'est son donc de nous sentir coupable
d'être inactif
et d'associer l'inactivité à la paresse
rappelez-vous
quand vous étiez enfant
quand dans votre tête vous étiez une
princesse ou un capitaine pirate
quand le mot paresseux était associé à
Sid dans L'âge de glace
n'est-ce pas bon de ne se soucier que de
l'instant présent
alors dans le futur et dès demain
je vous invite à déconnecter
à prendre des temps de pause loin de
votre smartphone à vous libérer de
toutes les addictions qui faussent votre
perception du temps
je vous invite à vous ennuyer à penser
à imaginer votre futur
[Musique]
allez-y émerger vos désirs vos besoins
et vos ambitions en cohérence avec vos
valeurs
enfin plus que tout je vous invite à
profiter de l'instant
à prendre le temps pour chacune de vos
tâches à vivre la minute sans penser à
la suivante
c'est en prenant le temps qu'on se
soucie le moins de l'avenir et que l'on
profite le plus
c'est donc de cette manière que je vous
invite à penser le temps dans ce monde
où tout s'accélère et où tout va
toujours plus vite
pour clôturer
je souhaite citer la sociologue Élise
bolding qui a dit si on est tout le
temps essoufflé mentalement à gérer le
présent
il ne nous reste plus d'énergie pour
imaginer l'avenir
merci à tous